[MUSIC PLAYING]
KATHARINA PROBST:
We're here to talk
about cost-effective cluster
sharing with GKE multi-tenancy.
If you listened to
yesterday's keynote,
you heard [INAUDIBLE]
talk about how
it is very important
for our customers
to deliver value to their
own customers quickly
and to be able to
iterate quickly.
I'm sure this is very important
to all of you as well.
And of course, our
customers and you as well
want to deliver value to your
customer at the minimum cost
possible.
So we're here to talk about how
a GKE multi-tenancy strategy
fits into this picture.
My name is Katharina Probst.
I work at Google, and I'm going
to spend a few minutes talking
about why GKE multi-tenancy
is something that you
might want to consider.
Shahid Masud will talk
about the what and the
how of multi-tenancy.
And then finally, Karl
Isenberg from Cruise Automation
will give us a
customer perspective,
a real world scale use case
of multi-tenancy in practice.
So let's spend just a
couple of minutes talking
about why multi-tenancy.
At a glance,
Kubernetes is a user
or a set of users
interacting with a master.
Master holds the API server,
the scheduler, other things.
And the master is
responsible for managing
a set of nodes that run
your actual application.
All right?
So when you have one
cluster and one user,
things are relatively
straightforward, right?
User interacts with the master.
A master manages the nodes.
But what happens when
you have multiple users
in multiple clusters?
So think, for
instance, if you have
many teams in your
own organization that
have to run different
applications
or even external customers that
run different applications.
So what happens when you set
up a separate Kubernetes stack
for each one of your users?
And I want to give
you two things
to think about, going back
to our cost and velocity
arguments.
So think about how this
scales financially.
Having a completely separate
stack, if you look at this,
one of the things
you will notice
is that you now
have a proliferation
of these clusters, right?
And one of the things that you
now don't have the easy ability
to do anymore is
to share resources
among these applications.
This is something that
we hear from customers
and that also gels
with my own experience.
Oftentimes, what
you have is you have
applications that run at
different times of the day.
So you might have
some applications that
take a lot of user
traffic during the day,
and then you might have some
applications that you can run,
for instance, batch applications
that you can run at night.
And you want to have the ability
to use one set of resources
to run both of these easily.
Another thing to
think about is how
does this proliferation of
clusters scale operationally?
This is also something that's
very close to my heart.
If you have a lot of
different clusters running,
now you have tens, or hundreds,
or thousands of dashboards
that you need to
understand and manage.
Now you have to figure out how
to apply policies across all
of those consistently.
You have to figure out how to
apply, for instance, networking
or other kinds of setups
consistently across all
of them.
How do you roll out new
versions, and so forth?
So those are the
kinds of things where
if you reach a certain
scale, it becomes
more difficult to manage
all of these clusters.
Now an alternative
to this approach
of setting up a separate
cluster for each app
is to have a shared cluster,
so a multi-tenant cluster.
And the way this
will work, generally,
is that you have a large cluster
with a large set of nodes.
And you split it
up by namespace,
and assign an application
to a namespace.
And now you can
have multiple users
that own different applications
running in the same cluster.
One pattern that we've seen--
and that Karl will talk
about in greater detail--
is different teams having their
different applications that
run in different
namespaces, as I just said,
on a shared Kubernetes cluster
or set of Kubernetes clusters.
And then that also
gives you the ability
to build platforms
on top of that.
That, again, gets
you to this place
where you can be far more
consistent across all
of the apps that are running
on these shared clusters.
Now with that, I will hand it
off to my colleague, Shahid,
and he will talk about the what
of multi-tenancy and the how.
SHAHID MASUD: All right.
So first, let's try
to be on the same page
in terms of what
multi-tenancy means.
In our context, we're
looking at features
that are part of
Kubernetes Engine that
support multi-tenancy.
And from the Kubernetes
Engine point of view,
the things that we
want to be able to do
are to provide isolation
and fair resource
sharing for the
users of a cluster
within one single cluster.
So we want to make sure
that the users aren't
able to hog resources or
step on each other's doors
as they're sharing one cluster
in a multi-tenant environment.
The other thing to understand
is what your tenants are like.
So you can think of your tenants
as whether you trust them,
whether you somewhat trust them,
or whether they're untrusted.
So a trusted tenant
would be teams
within one company, where
you know what kind of code
they're deploying.
You may have some audit
processes or some other checks
and balances that make sure that
only certain type of components
get deployed in your cluster.
So that's what I mean
by a trusted tenant.
You may not have as rigorous
audit procedures in place.
And the tenants, you
still trust them,
but they can deploy any sort
of code in the cluster as well.
And on the other
extreme, you have
non-trusted users or tenants
who can deploy anything.
Basically, you're
providing a platform
where users bring their code.
And they run that
code on your platform.
So if you have the
non-trusted tenants,
you may want to look
at this new feature
with GKE called GKE
Sandbox, which uses gVisor
to add an extra
layer of security
between the container
and the infrastructure.
So it provides defense
in-depth capabilities
without requiring much
change in the application.
So you may want to see
this session, which
we will talk more in
detail about multi-tendency
using Sandbox.
Back to this session,
we are focusing mainly
on the use case, where
you trust the tenants
and you know the kind
of code that they're
deploying in the cluster.
So with that out of
the way, let's look
at how you might
implement multi-tenancy.
There are four
things that you want
to be careful of when you're
setting up multi-tenancy.
You want to set up the
right access control.
You want to set up the right
way of resource sharing,
a fair way of resource sharing.
You want to be able to isolate
certain users and workloads
from other workloads and users.
And then you finally want to
see what your users are actually
doing.
You want to see how much
resources they're using
and so on and so forth.
So let's look at each in detail.
First, let's look
at access control.
So GCP at a higher level
provides a mechanism
of access control using
Projects and Identity and Access
Management.
So Project is a high
level primitive,
which allows you to
sort of group resources
and then allows you to
provide rules to users within,
for those resources.
So one key takeaway
here is that when
you add a rule for a
user for a project,
it applies to all the
clusters in that user.
So if you give someone the
Kubernetes Engine developer
role for a project, they'll have
that role for any clusters that
are contained in that project.
So for that reason, one
thing that we recommend
to our customers is to
separate your environments
at least in different projects.
So your production environment
should be one project,
and your nonprod could be
another project as well.
So that way, if you give
someone access to the nonprod,
they don't automatically
have access to the production
environment as well.
So that's one key
point to remember.
And then within
the clusters, you
have the boundary of
namespaces that you
can use to separate
out different users
and tenants within the cluster.
So next, let's look
at how the users
are authenticated and authorized
to use resources in a cluster.
So it's a three-step process.
There's authentication,
authorization,
and then there's
admission control.
The authentication is provided
by the IAM that we saw earlier.
So the rules that the
users have in the project
would determine whether they
can access this cluster or not.
And at a minimum, you
need the get permission
on the container API of GKE to
be able to access this cluster.
And then it's up to the
role based access control
that are a part
of Kubernetes that
determine what that user
can do in the cluster.
So you want to set
up the right roles
and bind those roles
to those users.
So the roles come in two
flavors in Kubernetes.
One are cluster roles,
which are cluster wide.
So you want to be careful as
to who you give those roles
because these cluster
roles go across namespaces.
And since you're
limiting your tenants
to individual namespaces,
you're most likely
going to need to create the
roles for each namespace
and then give those roles
to the appropriate users
of that namespace.
And you can also--
you can bind these rules
with Google Groups as well.
This is a new beta
feature that has come out.
A lot of our customers were
requesting this feature,
so that they can assign
the roles or cluster
roles to Google Groups
and then manage users
by adding and removing
them from those groups.
Then the next step in the
process is admission control.
So before Kubernetes
resources persisted,
Kubernetes makes sure that it
meets your admission criteria.
And this is an
opportunity for you
to modify that and allow and
disallow certain objects.
Or you can change those objects
to add some default values
or change them to
meet your policy.
So that's another mechanism
that's available to you
to do that.
One more feature-- so
those are for the users.
How about the workloads that
are running in your system?
So this is another area
where our customers
have to do some manual
workarounds to get past that.
We have a new feature,
which is hitting beta soon,
called Workload Identity.
What it allows you to do
is use GCP service accounts
to give your workloads
access to GCPD resources
without you having
to manage the keys
or providing these
keys to the pods.
GCP will take care
of that for you.
And this resolves a
number of workarounds
that our customers had
to implement in the past.
And typically, you
either use the identity
of the node where the
workload is running
to access GCP resources.
But you can imagine in a
multi-tenant environment,
that's not desirable
because the same node can
be hosting different types of
workloads for different users.
So you don't want to do that.
And it also takes
the burden away
from the administrators of
either downloading the key,
and then manually managing
that key, and providing that
to the workloads that they want.
So that's a great new feature
that supports multi-tenancy.
And there's a detailed
talk on that feature
also that you may want
to look at to understand
that feature in more detail.
So next, let's look
at resource sharing.
Kubernetes, as I said,
has a lot of sort
of mechanisms built into
it to allow you to do that.
You can define quotas, which is
the aggregate sort of resources
that a namespace can have.
You can add default values for
resource limits and requests
that the users can make
for their workloads.
You can also use pod
affinity and anti-affinity
to sort of split the workloads
across different nodes
and sort of isolate
them from each other.
And then pod
priority can be used
to sort of prioritize different
workloads over the other.
So high priority workloads
can preempt lower priority
workloads as well.
Next, let's look at
runtime isolation.
Again, there are a
number of features.
I already mentioned
Sandbox pods that you
can use to provide an
extra layer of security
between the containers and audit
what the containers can do.
You can also set up the pod
security policies and security
contacts, which allow you to
limit what resources the pod
can access, whether it can
access the file system,
or it can run in
the host network,
and so on and so forth.
And network policy
also allows you
to determine which pods
are able to communicate
with one another, what
sort of network access
those pods will allow.
So these are sort
of primitives that
are built into either Kubernetes
or the Kubernetes Engine
that you can use.
One challenge that this poses
is there's a lot of policies
that you have to manage.
How do you apply those policies
across multiple clusters
that you might
have and namespaces
within those clusters.
And also, how do you ensure
that the policies that you
want applied don't drift?
People don't come in
and change the policy,
and you want to have better
control on that policy.
And that's where a new
feature called Anthos Config
Management comes in.
How many of you watched
the keynote yesterday?
So the keen observers may
have seen the Anthos Config
Management being
used during the demo
that they showed for Anthos to
apply the different policies
or changes to your cluster.
What it allows you to do
is to define your policy
in a center place.
You can check that into a
repo, so you can version
control that.
And then Config Management will
automatically pull that policy
and apply it to all the
clusters that are enrolled
in that Config Management.
So I'll give you a brief demo
of that to show how that works.
So I have a cluster where
I don't have any workloads
running right now.
And I have defined my policy
into this repo that I have.
And you can define any
Kubernetes native resource.
It doesn't have to be
just those policies.
You can define the quota.
Here, I have a
quota defined, where
I can have 70 pods in
each namespace and so on.
And I can also
define deployment.
So if you wanted to have
some workloads running
by default in those namespaces,
you can define that as well.
So I have this workload that
I'm running in this namespace
as well.
So next, what I'll
do is I will apply
that policy in that cluster.
So I have the config management
operator already running
in the cluster.
And this is the
operator that's looking
at custom resources that
define where your policy should
be pulled from.
So the way you do that is
you define a custom resource
of type config management.
And you pointed to the repo
where your policy exists.
So in this case, I'm
pointing it to the repo
that I just showed you.
And I can specify which branch
it should pull the policy from
and apply it to the cluster.
So I'm using master.
Depending on your own
sort of branching policy,
you can choose the
branch that you want.
So what I'll do next is
I will apply this policy
into my cluster.
And what that is doing is--
essentially, what
this will do is
it will create that
policy in the cluster.
So one thing you'll notice is
if I go back to the workloads,
it will start a
few processes that
will start pulling the
policy from the git repo
and start applying it
in your cluster as well.
So once this policy has been
applied, what you will notice
is that anything that
I've defined in this repo
will be applied to that cluster.
And the namespaces that I've
defined-- blue, and green,
and carmine--
and the quota that I've defined
will be applied to that cluster
as well.
So while the policy
is applied, I just
want to point out
a few things here.
One thing is that you can--
since your policy and
all of your resources
are checked into a repo, you can
use your sort of built pipeline
to make sure that any
changes in the policy
are validated
through some tests.
They're reviewed--
whatever process
you have for the review.
And then once the
review is complete,
and you merge those changes
back into the branch
that you want to
apply to the cluster,
that Config Management will
automatically deploy it
in the cluster for you.
And another great feature
of Config Management
is that if someone tries
to go in the cluster
and change some of
those policies--
they try to change
some of those values--
Config Management will
detect that change.
And it will reapply that
change back and make sure
that the cluster conforms to the
checked in policy in the repo.
So it will continuously
reconcile the changes
in the policy with
what's in the repo.
So let's go back and
see if this has started.
So as you can see,
it started that.
And the other thing
that you would
notice is the hello,
world deployment that I
had defined in here has been
created in the cluster as well.
So let's say if you wanted
to change some of those--
so let's say I want
to change the quota.
I want to make a change.
So what I can do
is I can, again,
follow my workflow for pushing
changes to the git repo.
So here, I have a change
that I have made to the quota
that I want to apply to the
repo-- to the cluster as well.
So what I will do is
I'll add that change.
And then I will
commit that change.
And once I push that
change into the repo,
Config Management will
automatically apply that change
into the cluster.
And now if I look at the
quota in that namespace, what
you will see is that
the quota is 50,
and it has changed
from 72 down to 50.
So this is an easy way to make
sure that your policies always
stay in sync with whatever
you've defined in your repo.
So getting back-- so there's
a more detailed session,
where we talk about
the Config Management.
So you may want to check
out that session as well.
It's later tomorrow.
So let's finally
look at how do you
get to know what your tenants
are up to in the cluster
as well.
So for that, we
have a new feature
in GKE called Usage Metering.
What it allows you to do is
capture the resource usage
that your users have
in the namespaces
that they've been assigned to.
So you can capture
usage of memory CPU
and other resources
in the cluster.
It will put that data
in a BigQuery data
set that you can later
analyze and visualize as well.
The important thing is
this does not automatically
generate the billing
data for those tenants,
but you can combine that data
with your GCP billing data
to figure out how to build
your tenants as well.
And you can visualize
that data using something
like Data Studio to see
what your tenants are doing.
So these are just some
of the features that can
help you set up multi-tenancy.
But we have a real use case
from Cruise Automation.
And I'd like to invite Karl
to come up here and walk us
through their use case.
KARL ISENBERG: Hey.
I'm Karl, and I'm
the tech lead manager
of the PaaS team at Cruise.
Cruise is doing self-driving
vehicles in San Francisco.
If you've been
around here a while,
you've probably seen our cars
driving around San Francisco.
And we try to connect people
with the places, things,
and experiences that they
care about doing this.
This is a visualization from one
of our other open source tools
that you can find more
information about on our blog.
But it's basically visualizing
the LiDAR data and our mapping
data together.
So one of the problems
we had at Cruise
when I started probably
a year and a half ago
is a cluster
proliferation problem.
So we had a whole bunch of SREs
that were deploying Kubernetes
clusters on AWS at the time.
And what we ended up with
was like one cluster per team
effectively.
Some of them were sharing.
Some of them weren't.
And they were all kind of
special little snowflakes.
Most of them weren't upgradable.
Some of them had default, still
configured one-year time bombs
on the route CA,
which would then
expire and then lead people
to frantically replacing them.
So one of the ways we solved
this later was moving to GKE,
but the way we did immediately
was to start up a PaaS team
to work on sort of centralizing
the development of a platform
as a service at Cruise
on top of Kubernetes.
At Cruise, we have
a lot of workloads
that are fairly diverse.
So we do ML and data processing,
backend services, reporting
batch jobs, productivity
tools, continuous deployment,
continuous integration,
platform add-ons.
And a lot of these were
already in containers.
So we were pretty Cloud native.
We're just trying to become
more production ready
before we launch our
services in the coming years.
So some of the reasons why we
went into multi-tenancy or why
we decided to invest
in multi-tenancy--
one was cost savings.
We already recognized that we
were spending a bunch of money
on these masters running
Kubernetes clusters.
And we didn't really
need them because we
weren't maximizing the masters.
In our proliferated
clusters, they also
weren't even highly
available masters.
So moving to a
central cluster allows
us to move faster with
that central cluster
and get it to a more
production ready mature state,
which helps us towards
our production readiness
goals of being easier to audit,
having central observability,
having dashboards
that were mature,
built-in backups, auto scaling,
all that kind of stuff,
that if you spread
out to your teams,
they might not get in the
same pace or even ever.
And then the other thing we
care about a lot was developer
productivity or velocity.
And so, some of this
was around centralizing
the ingress and egress for
NATs and load balancing.
And some of it was
around centralizing
Config Management,
and image building,
and continuous deployment.
Basically, all trying
to get our developers
to have to consider
less of that,
and also to free up
our SREs so that they
could focus on
other tasks, rather
than having to build
the platform themselves.
So at Cruise, we also have
a hybrid private network,
which kind of biased a bunch
of our decision making.
We already are in this
complex multi-cloud world,
where we have AWS, and GCP,
and on-premise resources.
And so connecting all this,
thankfully, the platform team
didn't have to do by ourselves.
We have a NetEng team
that works with us
and a good security team that
integrates with all of us
to sort of build out this
private networking platform.
But there's a whole
bunch of other pieces
underneath Kubernetes that
you need to be concerned about
and make sure that those are
also set up to be multi-tenant.
One of the ways we did that
was by, as was recommended,
having separate projects
for separate environments.
But we also did a
foldering structure
so that we could completely
isolate our production
environments and be able to
audit which projects in GCP
were production projects.
That way, we could easily
go see what their security
state was, what the logs were
for the production stuff.
And mostly security and other
teams that were going and doing
audits didn't have
to pay attention
as much to the
development because it
was completely isolated.
So we did these
folders, and then we
have teams that had
a set of projects.
And then these projects
are in each of the folders.
There's probably
multiple team folders.
So one of the
things that get put
in these folders or
these projects that
are in the folders
is like NetEng
manages its own
networking infrastructure
inside their own projects.
And then they share that
network with the other projects.
So none of the
other projects even
have a default network
local to those projects.
They just share the one
that's managed centrally.
And then the teams would want
to use their own SaaS products.
Sometimes they use
GCE stuff as well.
So Cloud SQL's a good example
of having your database
inside of your team's project.
So only the team has
access to that data.
The platform team doesn't
need or want access
to your production data.
The NetEng probably
doesn't either.
So it keeps a good
isolation between teams.
And then this also means that
the PaaS team or the platform
team can handle the
Kubernetes clusters
inside their own
project, which means
that while we have
control of those projects,
people outside of
the central team
don't have access to come play
around with the Kubernetes
settings.
They just get access
to the Kubernetes
that's running on it.
So in Kubernetes in GKE,
we also sort of emulated
this matrix of multi-tenancies.
So we have dev staging
and prod shared clusters.
And we also have namespaces that
are assigned to those teams.
So this satisfied a
good sort of MVP goal
of getting everybody
to only be able to see
what they needed access to.
So each of them
will run their pods.
Their pods are isolated
across environments.
And they're semi-isolated
between teams as well.
So the teams aren't stepping
on each other's toes.
So this is just a picture
of some of the pieces
we put together.
I think PaaS is a little
bit of a controversial term,
but in our context, GKE
by itself is not enough.
We put a whole bunch of
extra work and integrations
into providing a platform
for our internal tenants.
So some of that
is GCE components.
Most of these
little ones in boxes
are GCP components
or configurations.
So we have public and private
load balancing routes,
which are a little bit
different because GCP
has different functionality
for different features.
And then we control those
with controllers that are then
integrating with GKE and
then those controllers either
have annotations or CRDs that
are in the Kubernetes API
so that our tenants can
self-service into the selection
of those features.
We also have a whole bunch
of security observability
and deployment functionality
that we provide as a service
to our internal tenants.
And that means that they
don't have to reinvent
the wheel every time.
And obviously, we didn't just
stamp all this out on day one.
It was sort of a
growing experience.
We've been doing this
for over a year now.
And we moved to GKE
about nine months ago.
So we took some of it from our
existing deployments and some
of it, we're still
[INAUDIBLE] out.
Like the external DNS
up there is a controller
for managing your DNS records.
We don't have that
automatic at the moment.
We're still doing terraforming.
So Vault integration
is one of the things
that we did early with help
from our [INAUDIBLE] team.
And our [INAUDIBLE] team
manages a highly available Vault
cluster.
And we decided to use
Vault for secrets,
instead of just Kubernetes
secrets, primarily
because it provides a
source of truth separate
from an individual cluster.
And this is a concern when
you have multiple clusters.
If you're small enough that
you can survive on one cluster,
and you don't want to
have multiple clusters
per environment, then you can
just use Kubernetes secrets.
But when you have this
proliferation of clusters,
you have to start
concerning yourself
about single source of truth
external to the cluster
and integrations.
So this is a fairly
standard pattern.
Our sort of contribution to
that is a Daytona init container
that we wrote that
authorizes with Vault
and downloaded the
secrets using--
let me step back.
It logs into Vault using the
service account that's injected
into your Kubernetes pod.
So that's a default
Kubernetes feature,
and then a Vault configuration
feature that's baked in.
And then Daytona we added
that does sort of the glue
to stick it together.
It uses it in-memory volume.
That's to make sure it doesn't
write anything to disk,
and it won't get
persisted outside
of the lifecycle of your pod.
And then it slurps it in through
an app container, volume mount.
So that you can either read
it from your application,
or your application
can have an entry point
script that converts from a
file to an environment variable.
So another thing we did is GCP
service account integration
through Vault. So
as was mentioned,
the pod identity feature
was not available
when we started doing this.
And so one of the things
this allows us to do
is provide the pods
with their own identity
from Vault using a
GCP service account.
So that means that we can
authorize these things
before the pod exists.
And the pod can go out
and perform GCP actions.
And probably the primary one
is talking to the database.
So they use that with a sidecar
proxy to talk to Cloud SQL,
for example.
So once you get into this sort
of central managing a Vault,
you end up having to manage
your namespaces in Vault
a little more carefully.
You can't just have
everybody writing secrets
wherever they want.
So what we went with
was some prefix that's
specific to us and then sort
of a namespacing pattern that
allows for isolating
the environments,
and the namespace, and
the application secrets,
which means that I
can say this team
has permission to write
to all of the environment
secrets for all of
the applications
under their namespace.
But other teams
don't have access
to even see or list those.
And then the
application itself only
has access to see the
secrets for its environment
for that specific app
for that namespace.
And that allows us to granularly
control permissions in Vault.
And we ended up doing sort
of [INAUDIBLE] workflow
to provision Vault configuration
in order to enable that.
Another thing we did was
group our own bindings.
So we open sourced it
about six months ago.
And this was to make up for
the lack of role binding, which
is a beta feature now
for Google Groups.
But it didn't used to exist.
And we built in a couple
more features into this.
So one of the things that
was explained earlier
is that you can't necessarily
use the project level
roles in order to bind
at the namespace level.
So what we had to do was
build out namespace admin,
namespace editor,
and namespace viewer,
and give those to
individual groups.
So we map those to
groups, and the team
gets that group membership.
That means I can have
our Google Group,
and there's some
manager that owns it.
And the manager just goes,
adds new team members
or removes team
members that leaves.
And then they don't have
to perform a role binding
manually.
This RBAC sync functionality
is a controller
that will watch a
configuration in a CRD.
And the CRD says this
group gets this permission,
and so then it will map
that out to the bindings
by reading through Google
Groups to figure out
who's in the group.
Another functionality
that we stuffed into this
was the ability to put
service accounts in groups
because currently, Google
Groups don't support that.
So what that means is
that we can give a service
account a specific role
and then add it to a group
whenever we make new
service accounts.
And we can use GCP
service accounts
to do that, rather than just
Kubernetes service accounts.
So there's a couple
of things that
are sort of unsolved or bleeding
edge problems that we're still
kind of trying to work on.
So one of those is
Kubernetes operators
in a tenancy environment.
The CRDs are global
definitions in Kubernetes,
so you can't necessarily
allow your namespace tenants
to create CRD definitions.
So what we do is we, as
a cluster operating team,
deploy CRD definitions and then
allow them to make CRD resource
objects in their namespace.
But that means you can only
have one sort of permutation
of that CRD at a time
because CRDs weren't
designed for multi-tenancy.
So that means we're
effectively helping
people deploy operators.
Also, the Container
Registry is a tenant.
Tenant dies at the
level of Google
projects, or GCP
projects, rather.
So if you want full
isolation between teams,
every team has to
manage their own GCR.
Otherwise, what we do is we host
a central one for development
purposes and give
everybody like admin to it.
That means they have push
and delete functionalities.
And then everybody
can push to that,
but we don't allow pulling
from that for the production
cluster.
So our production
cluster, we only
give access to service accounts.
And those service
accounts are then
used in continuous
integration or building.
So all of the
containers that run
on our production environment
we know were pushed from CI.
Stackdriver Logging
also is tenantized
at the project level.
And because you have
a shared cluster,
that means that all of the logs
from all of your containers
are admitted to the same
shared project, which
creates a little
bit of a problem
because we've only given people
view access to that project.
We didn't want to give
them editor access
to step on each
other's toes, which
means they can't make
log to metric conversions
or log dashboards.
So in order to
enable that, we had
to build a fan out system
that will take [INAUDIBLE]
Stackdriver and admits
to other projects
from specific namespaces.
DataDog metrics-- we use
DataDog instead of Stackdriver
for our metrics right now.
And primarily, that allows
us to aggregate them all.
But it's also not
super multi-tenant.
So you might have both a
fan out and a fan in problem
with both logging and metrics.
Because your auditors might
want to see all of them,
and your teams just want to
see the ones they care about.
So GCP has the ability to slurp
all your logs into one auditing
project.
So we use that for auditing,
and then we use this other fan
out solution for the tenants.
Spinnaker's another one where
we had to build our own operator
to make Spinnaker more isolated.
Because we have so
many namespaces--
we have 20 namespaces per
cluster and maybe a dozen
clusters--
that means that we are doing
account binding and role
binding in the
Spinnaker to isolate
who can deploy to
what from Spinnaker,
which is a little complicated.
And then on resource
isolation, probably one
of the weaknesses of Kubernetes
in general for multi-tenancy
is that there are some things
that are not well isolated yet.
So CPU and memory are great.
They're isolated
you opt into it,
and then you have that
amount of resource.
It even has preemption on those.
But local disk space, there is
a beta feature in Kubernetes
that isn't in GKE yet.
So we can't isolate that yet.
Disk I/O is completely on
isolated in Kubernetes,
so if you are on spinning
hard drives, which
I don't recommend,
you can actually
knock over the Docker
daemon if you use
too much disk at the same time.
So we switched to SSDs,
and that has mostly
eliminated the problem.
But it's still unisolated.
Ingress and egress--
I mentioned us having solved
those sort of at the platform
level, but they're also
a little bit unisolated.
One of the ways
we're hoping to get
towards isolation in the
future here is with Istio.
So Istio adds the
sidecars to each container
and allows you to monitor
the ingress and egress
from every container,
which allows you to do
sort of traffic management.
But Kubernetes doesn't
come with that by default.
So there's a whole
bunch of things
we also want to do that we
haven't done just to sort of be
an example of all of the things
that you might want to consider
when you're building
not just a Kubernetes
cluster, but a multi-tenant,
multi-environment, private
cloud hybrid network cluster.
So one of the things
I would recommend
is to put in your
defaults and quotas
before you put
tenants on your system
because what we've learned is
now that we've gone and had
people on our systems,
we can't add quotas
without breaking them.
So we have to do an analysis
on who's using what,
and then make them
per namespace quotas,
and then add a GitOps
approval process and all
that kind of stuff.
So that's a little complicated.
Do that upfront.
We would also like to
go to project isolation
instead of team isolation.
And what I mean by that is
reducing the blast radius
of a compromised project.
So if someone comes
in through a web app
API or something
compromises a web app,
and then they have
control over the container
for whatever one weakness
in your application,
you don't want it to
be on the same network
in the same namespace
with everything
else that team is running.
You want to sort of
reduce the blast radius.
So there's a bunch of
different ways to do that.
One of them is with by
having smaller namespaces,
and another one is by doing
this sort of network policy
that restricts who
has access to what.
Another one is with
pod security policy
with reducing what the
pods can actually do.
And then a couple of these other
functionalities-- web hooks
have been talked a lot about
a bunch in the Kubernetes
environment or
ecosystem for sort
of restraining or
enforcing what people
can apply to your cluster.
But there's no sort of off
the shelf solution for that.
There's OPA, which is a policy
sort of administrator that
can do some web hooks
for you, but there's
no built-in policies that
you can just slap in place.
So there's some work
to be done there.
And then we would also like
an automated build system.
I'd really love a Docker
hub automated build
for on-premise
behind my firewall,
but it doesn't really exist.
So there's a couple of
different products you can use.
Cloud Builder is one of them.
Knative Build is another one.
So we're going to
be working on that.
Microsegmentation of the network
also reduces blast radius.
Security would love
us to get to that.
We're hoping to get there with
Istio and network policies.
And usage media metering
was talked about.
It's great.
We're going to get there,
but because it is still beta,
we haven't played with it.
And then service
RBAC is also kind of
important with your users to
services or user to Kubernetes.
That's built in with GKE.
You get your Google
user auth, and then you
can do role binding
against users.
But once your
application is running,
how do your applications
authorize with each other?
And this is kind of a problem
everybody has to solve.
And there's no out of the box
solution that I know of yet.
End to end TLS is another one.
GKE doesn't come
with this built in.
You can use sort of a let's
encrypt controller solution.
But we wanted one
that would allow
us to do both public
and private domains.
So then we need to
host our own CA,
and automate the
controller for it,
and then make it different
from the public one,
that kind of thing.
Plus, we don't really want to
be inserting TLS certificates
into every pod.
We'd rather inject
to the load balancer,
and then have Service
Mesh handle the last mile
encryption.
That way, we're
not putting secrets
that can be compromised
down into the pods.
We have sort of a two-layer
encryption scheme.
So basically,
moral of the story,
if you're big enough to
build a platform here
on top of Kubernetes,
which Kubernetes
is a platform for
building platforms,
then you're probably big
enough to make it multi-tenant.
Multi-tenancy does
require additional work
on top of Kubernetes.
And I wouldn't necessarily
say it's for everyone.
But if your alternative
is multi-environment or
multi-instance,
then you're going
to have to build some layer
underneath it that allows you
to deploy a bunch of clusters.
And so if you're already
building a layer,
you might as well make
it multi-tenant instead.
So there's obviously
tradeoffs and pros and cons,
so take it with a grain of
salt. But that's our experience.
And I think we've got
it working pretty well.
If you go in a car in Cruise or
you see those driving around,
those are all
talking to our cloud
with the backend running
on multi-tenant Kubernetes.
[APPLAUSE]
SHAHID MASUD: All right.
Thank you, Karl, for
sharing the journey
of Cruise Automation
to using Kubernetes
in a multi-tenant fashion.
I just want to close out with
a few key sort of takeaways.
So by centralizing,
Kubernetes has
a lot of learning that you
have to do to understand
how to run it well.
And by specializing that
knowledge with one team
that operates your clusters not
only builds that sort of center
of excellence, which allows
you to implement the best
practices across
multiple clusters,
but it also frees
up your developers
to spend their time on
developing stuff that
adds value to your company.
So I think that's some
of the key takeaways.
And then it gives you the
operational efficiency
by letting that
specialized team to manage
those clusters for you.
And it also saves you
some infrastructure cost
by consolidating a large
number of clusters into fewer
multi-tenant clusters as well.
And GKE has some
new features that
can help you set up
that multi-tenancy.
As we heard from
Karl and Cruise,
there's still some
work to be done.
And you'll see those
features come out as well.
[MUSIC PLAYING]